Fresno California Melanie is with us hi
Melanie how are you hey Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up in your
world of course one question I'm about
11 months from retiring I tips I
normally have about 25,000 and debt that
I'm going to be finished up and here
probably within my goal is within the
next two years but my question is I put
in I was maxing out my Roth IRA IRA and
then I backed it down so I could put
more money towards the debt and my
question to you is should I continue to
put money towards the raw am pit debt or
what what's your suggestion on that only
talking about 20 months right uh 20
months well I'm gonna retire in 11
months um I you know I can't take the
money out of course on 59 and a half but
I'm wondering what how old are you I'll
be 50 I'm 49 what are you gonna do what
am I gonna do I retire uh-huh
vacation mostly you're going to just
completely stop work at 50 years old
yeah I really won't have to work based
on my income and what is your income my
incomes 110 a year when you retire uh
just about there probably go down to
about 90 and what is that from pension
from state yeah okay
and so you're really you're honest and
10 is to do nothing the rest of your
life well not nothing but at first the
first couple years I'm going to do some
travel and I may do something else later
on but it's in the meantime I'm just
going to stick it for a couple of years
and just you know enjoy retirement until
I decide what I want to do or if I want
to do anything at all okay well that's
not to shame you but you cannot do a
Roth if you don't have an earned income
that's why I was asking why and that's
why I was wanting to know whether or not
I should continue to put money in the
wrong yeah I'm trying to feed out my
debt yes in your case you should and
okay because you're not gonna be able to
after eleven months right okay you're
gonna be able to a Roth and it
shir so every year you have to have at
least your your $5,500 in our 6500 if
you're over 50 you can do into a Roth um
you have to have at least that much in
earned income on your tax return which
is earned income means wage income or
self-employed income not investment or
pension income in order in order to do
your Roth so I would do all I can do for
this period of time hopefully you can I
don't know how that eleven months if
it's love months from today you're
straddling two calendar years so you do
it twice and then get yourself on out of
that as fast as possible and then I
would just tell you too that you're
probably not you know you're probably
going to have a more enjoyable life if
you find something to do with yourself
after you finish a couple of years of
traveling and usually that involves
earning an income you're going to have a
more enjoyable life this idea that we
vacation for 40 years in May and that's
enjoyable truthfully it's not there's
all kinds of studies that show it's just
not that fun this is the Dave Ramsey
show
and